three two one
good morning members good morning
members of the public
you're all very welcome to this meeting
of the planning committee of baby
district council
first of all may i remind you of some of
the domestic
arrangements members please
please ensure that the microphones and
cameras are turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
if you wish to speak point of order
declaration
interest or request an adjournment
please use the hands up function on the
taskbar
and after you've spoken please remember
to turn it off
members are reminded that they should
not have alternative communication lines
open i.e other scope chats
and that if you are contacted by a third
party
during an application you should bring
this to the attention of the legal
advisor if you are attending the meeting
to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked
to leave if members do lose connection
to the meeting
that they must contact the member
support officer
mandy smith as soon as possible you all
would have her numbers
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated feelings
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be
deemed by the council to have consented
to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those same
recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the public and press may
record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press
are not lawfully excluded
i'd no longer uh introduce you to
the officers supporting us today it's
mark russell
area planner manager linda bacon case
officer indy press
planner lawyer robert carmichael
governance officer
and caroline yepman heritage officer
now i intend to move to the agenda
first of all i'm going to ask for um
present and substitutions
um i'm going to call on robert to
go through the roll call for members
thank you chair
so just do the roll call so if you could
please respond with present or good
morning
so councillor suez good morning
councilman elaine barrett
yes present counselor peter beer present
counselor trevor chris will
present thank you councillor uh just a
note counselor chris was subbing for
councillor allison owen
councillor busby president
councillor gould yes good morning and
just a note there as well
uh councillor gould is substituting for
councillor lee jameson today
thank you councillor hinton president
councillor mary mclaren present council
adrian osborne
morning present castle lee parker
present casa stephen plum present
and we have the ward member as well this
one of the ward members because
counselor trevor cresswell is on the
committee today
of councillor jan osborne as well
thank you
item two to receive any declarations of
interest by members are there any to
declare
no i can't say any hands up no chairman
may i yeah i'm coming to you now yep
the legal officer and yes thank you
chair um i should just give it uh i want
to give a quick piece of advice here
which is that
um it's stating the obvious this
actually part of this
application site is a con is an old
conservative club still named as such
and
a casual observer might have some cause
for concern
but um if we look at this matter more
closely the um
the applicant as it says in your report
is raj is not
the conservative party either nationally
or a local conservative association
it is not um it is rogerson holdings
limited with mr peasland who's here with
us as their agent
i've i've inquired i'm told that the
landowner is not a con
specifically conservative association
local or otherwise
so uh and i understand that this and
indeed it's made clear to some degree in
the papers that
it's not been used as for its original
purpose as a conservative club for
several years maybe 10 years or so
so with all that in mind none of the
conservative members of this committee
need to feel any embarrassment or
um obvious um declarative need to
declare any interest
in determining this matter but having
said that the normal rules apply as they
do in every application of every member
if you think you might have a
interest or a a worry as to whether you
should be a decision maker that or to be
declared anyway but that's
that is just my advice on this massive
so far
thank you very much that's very clear no
i i certainly don't
and there's no hands going up so i'm
assuming everybody's quite happy with
that
all right we'll move to the next item
and that's to confirm the minutes
um of the last meetings
held on the 15th of july are there any
points of accuracy
on these
no right i need a proposal and a second
to them please
close that mr chairman councillor
osborne thank you very much to have a
second day
yes i'll i'll second it councillor
barrett
thank you
we'll do another roll call or do you
want to do all these in one
no i think we better do them separate so
you'll need to do a roll call then um
robert thank you chair so
um if you could please respond with
fought against or abstain
so councillor sue is four
counselor melanie barrett four
counselor peter beer four
councilman trevor cresswill abstain
counselor david busby oh
counselor jane gould stone
counselor john hinton
come back to him yeah did he get me
there
hello sorry if you could just repeat
your vote thank you cancer
council mary mclaren paul
counselor adrian osborne
that's a lee parker abstain
and counselor stephen plum
thank you chair that is carried thank
you these will be signed at the next
practical opportunity
we need to move on to confirm the
minutes of the meet and held on the 26th
of
august you've all seen them um are there
any
points that people wish to clarify your
accuracy
no hands up up uh then i need a proposed
under secondary gain
i'll propose them right oh second second
thank you very much and councillor
barrett has seconded them
i'll ask rob to do a roll call again
thank you
thank you chair same procedure as before
please if you could respond with four
against or abstain
so councillor suez four
council melanie barrett four
councillor peter beer four
councillor trevor cresswell abstain
counselor david busby full
council jangled capstone
counselor john hinton
counselor mary mclaren
counselor adrian osborne
cancer lee parker abstain
counselor stephen plum four
thank you chair i make that carried by
votes
yes i agree thank you very much that's
accepted
and then they also will be signed at the
next practical opportunity
now do we have another set of minutes
rob
uh no chair that was both of them that
was both of them you've got them in line
good right um then we'll move on to
receive
any notification of any petitions in
accordance with the
council's scheme uh robert michael
uh sorry chair just before interrupt uh
councillor parker's got his hand up
sorry if we both
oh right sorry he hasn't come up the
side he's come along the bottom of my
screen i must look there as well um
sorry uh councillor parker i wasn't
looking there i was looking at the side
uh yes
no no problem sharon actually um i'm
sorry because i've just realized but i
mean i've given my vote now so it
doesn't matter but um i've just realized
in the
i wasn't listening to i apologize in the
first set of minutes i was present for
actually i voted to abstain but um
happy to go with that if uh if that's
the correct procedure yeah i'll ask that
well i think i think the vote has been
given and it would the change of vote
it's a practical formality and that the
vote would i think we just let it lie as
it is i think you'd be the same mind mr
michael yeah it's just noted that so
we're clear and he's clear that's fine
thank you very much uh councillor parker
uh right sorry rob petitions yep so
there's uh
sorry chair there's none received thank
you very much
site inspections officers are there any
site inspection requests
uh mark wherever you are yeah uh yes
chair uh obviously you'll be aware that
um
counselor jan osborne had asked whether
we could look at this site
uh today but the response given was
still that we're not doing site visits
at the moment
thank you um
i think county are looking at trying to
bring back some of their site
inspections in october
but because after the last 24 hours that
made it all change again
my colleagues from ipswich aren't doing
them at all at the moment so there is
there is a variety of
um approaches okay thank you
members i have to ask you are there any
site inspection requests
no thank you sorry can i just ask
if we wanted a site inspection of um
could there be a video
uh made by the planning officer so that
that would allow us to sort of visit
virtually
good point we did this for the worst of
applications and i think it's a sensible
approach to be honest because then
you've got
as we did last time have it up before
the meeting you've got a chance to look
around the site
so it's a good idea
so there's a possibility yeah thanks
thanks
thank you
right then we move to planning
applications
on page 23 victoria hall new street
sudbury
um and
linda baker you're taking us through
that if you'd like to
carry on
thank you chair and good morning members
so hopefully the presentation is now
appearing on your screen
so i'll continue yes it is this
is a it's a full application for
development of the site that includes
victoria hall
the conservative club and new hall
this aerial image puts the site in some
context
um north street which is the top end
north end of uh sudbury is is here
the masonic hall is on this corner here
this is new street running down here
and prince street runs crossways here
and the prince of wales public house is
on the corner here
the road here is the a131 it's the
one-way system that runs through
sudbury
hello you've disappeared
hello can you still hear me we can know
yep
yeah i think the slides are taking a
long time to change
right okay we'll bear that in mind we're
still on number two
yeah right slide
three hopefully you can now see so this
shows the uh constraints map the
um the purple hatching is the
conservation area so the sites within
the conservation area
um the list of buildings as shown in
orange
and the site is hatched
all three buildings that are on the site
that's the victoria hall
the conservative club and new hall
itself they're all on the sudbury list
and are locally listed
non-designated heritage assets
this site location plan outlines the
application site in red
new hall is the the long building to the
rear
victoria hall and the conservative club
occupy the corner of prince street and
new street here
the conservative club is roughly
in this area and fronts on to new street
whereas victoria hall
is here and fronts on to prince street
so this shows the existing elevations
the top image
shows the existing elevations of new
hall
it's an elongated single story building
with banks of small paint windows that
um
that point to its historical use as a
silk manufacturer
and it has historical associations to
local industry and as such
it makes a deserved entry onto the local
list
victoria hall below is a 19th century
theater and it's connected to the
conservative club now and it's been used
in more recent years as part
or in connection with the conservative
club
the the top left image repeats the
victoria hall facade onto prince street
the top right is the elevation of the
conservative club fronting new
street the bottom left is the existing
block plan
for victoria hall and the conservative
club
victoria hall is this area to the rear
and the conservative club is this series
of buildings
to the front the the right hand image is
the
um the elevations that are within the
site itself
so previously there's been a planning
permission granted for the conversion or
the
the part conversion of victoria hall and
the full conversion of the conservative
club
into five flats this was a full planning
permission
which resulted in permission for two
flats in the
in the front section of victoria hall
and three flats in the conservative club
new hall itself which is the building
here was not part of that planning
permission
so this image shows the approved
elevations
for that flat conversion and that
introduced minimal external alterations
to the frontages
and that was approved as part of that
planning permission
for conversion and the change is mainly
related to to windows so there's minor
alterations to windows
so turning to the current proposal the
application comprises three elements
the first is the demolition of all but
the front facade
of victoria hall and the construction of
two dwellings behind the retained
facade to provide two four bed dwellings
with
garden area and car parking space behind
the second element is the full
demolition of the conservative club
in its entirety and the construction of
two three bedroom and two four bedroom
dwellings
that's here and the third element is the
partial demolition
in this area here of new hall to
facilitate parking and then there's the
conversion of
the north end of the remainder of new
hall
into a design studio or gallery
and at the southern end uh it will be
converted into a two bed dwelling
other than new hall the new hall
conversion itself
each dwelling in this area has
a small garden and two parking spaces
each
new hall itself will be provided with
one space for the dwelling here
and then there's one space for the
design studio gallery
here access to the site will be off
of north street itself which is it's a
little difficult to discern but
north street is up here and then the
access is in here round to the rear
the existing access at present is
located off of new street
in this area and that existing access
will be blocked off
by one of the new dwellings proposed
so turning to the elevations the the top
row of elevations
are the public elevations and so the top
left
fronts prince street and that's victoria
hall
and the top right is what will front new
street
uh in place of the conservative club
um remembering that the only facade that
will be retained is the front facade of
victoria
hall here all other built form is new
construction
the construction materials
on the prince street side
here comprise red brick red clay
plain tiles and beyond here is is slate
um on the new street frontage there's a
mix of materials so we've got
red brick there's then red cedar
cladding
there's render there's red clay plain
tiles
there's vertical cladding
there's red brick and i believe the roof
will be slate here
so the floor plans are a little
difficult to read but the bottom row
along here
is what's behind the victoria hall
facade and creates
two four bed dwellings over three floors
the top and the middle row are on the
site of the conservative club and
comprise two three beds
and that's over two stories and two four
beds over three stories
this uh plan is for the conversion
of new hall itself the dashed line here
indicates the demolition of three bays
of
new hall itself the floor plan shows the
creation of the two bed dwelling
on the southern end of what remains of
new hall and the design studio
is at the north end
many of you are going to be familiar
with the site but for those who aren't
i'll run through some photos
so this is the conservative club as it
is today fronting new street
the materials and the decorative
features which include
oreo windows and some detailed barge
boards should be
should be noted
this is an alternative view of the same
and
that's the old mill building um north
street is
is off to the right um
this shows the existing access and
the three-story building that's proposed
will be just short
of the the lean ii edition next door
a closer photo of the conservative club
fronting onto new street
prince of wales on the corner prince
street down here
so this is across the front of new
street looking towards north street at
the top
end the materials of the conservative
club change at this point from the galt
brick on the
new street side to red brick on the
prince street side
more of the same really looking up
towards north street this is
victoria hall itself fronting onto
prince street
um this one's self-evident
so victoria hall fronting prince street
uh one-way system at the end
the side of the prince of wales public
house is shown
another one of victoria hall onto prince
street
so this is new hall it's the side wall
of new hall
as it fronts onto the a131 one-way
system through the town
this being new hall here
a more distant view of new hall so to
the the left
you can see the um there's the existing
access
which will be utilized by this
development it's blocked off from the
one-way
system the a131 by the bollards but
entry is
off the top of north street this is new
hall
along the existing access that fence
will be removed as part of the
development
um closer view of new hall itself as to
say the fence will be removed
just to show you what the buildings look
like prior to some of the windows being
boarded up more recently
so these are taken from google street
view so this is of
victoria hall itself and then
this is um of the conservative club
building
taken from a few different views of uh
street view
so its detailed features can be seen
as is the the gabled ends um that front
onto new
street so that's just to give you a
flavor of what the building would look
like if you didn't have some of its
windows boarded
um so turning to the the key issues the
application the main summary the main
issues are summarized in bold here
there are other issues that are
highlighted in in the report but as
these aren't considered
to be significant issues i won't refer
to those now
the main issues relate to the fact that
the three existing buildings
are non-designated heritage assets
they're on the local list
and within the conservation air area
firstly any demolition must be fully
justified and secondly the replace
replacement building must preserve or
enhance the character and appearance of
the conservation area
officers consider that the proposed
development does neither
the structural reports submitted today
failed to provide sufficient
justification for the demolition but
instead conclude that retention and
conversion
of the existing would require
considerable expenditure to remedy
defects in the building however this
isn't explained or quantified in the
report
officers further consider that the
design of the proposal incorporates
elements that are inappropriate in the
conservation area
the variety of facing materials which
include red brick
and roof tiles and red cedar cladding
plus the design styles employed
do not preserve or enhance character and
appearance of the conservation area
the design of the replacement buildings
is such that it doesn't
outweigh the loss of architectural and
historic quality of the victoria hall
theatre
the conservation club and the new hall
silk factory
and this is a view that's reinforced in
comments received from the suffolk
preservation society
and the sudbury society and those
reported in detail
in your papers the application is
therefore recommended for
refusal as per your report and
for the reason shown here thank you
thank you very much for that uh linda um
members i'm just going to ask however
there's any points
that you'd like clarify by the case
officer
i've just got one linda you did say that
you you felt that it hadn't been um
justified or explained fully uh is this
relating to the fact that you've tried
to get points clarified and they haven't
been forthcoming
or are you still waiting for comments
or what did that mean um we're not still
waiting for additional comments
um it's felt that we've had two
structural
reports submitted the first
dealt with the the substructures
and the second looked at
um went beyond that um
and assessed the building in more detail
but the
the content of the report is is vague it
doesn't
explain why the building can't be
renovated or what methods could be
employed to retain some of it
we feel that there is insufficient
detail in the report
to be able to justify the demolition
right
thank you
uh thank you members is there any hands
going up any questions that you wanted
to ask
linda before if could i interrupt sorry
it's robin carmichael
um just to um just quickly raise a um
point that was um we might have covered
earlier is could we just confirm
before we go any further whether trevor
cresswell is
um sitting on the committee or
um or is attending to speak only as the
ward member
right uh councillor creswell um
the point is uh you're one of the two
members for sudbury
and you have a right to decide whether
you wish to be
the ward member and have five minutes in
which to address the committee
which you would be invited to comment
later on in it or you could remain a
member of the planning committee
which means that um you can take part in
the debate
all the time now it's entirely up to you
which way you wish to go
um peter i'd like to just stay a member
of the committee
thank you that's fine we do have your
fellow um sudbury member councillor
jan osborne who um will be speaking as
one of the ward members um but that will
come up later
thank you very much thank you robert for
reminding us
uh right members uh somebody's got a
hand up i don't know if that was
robert uh himself sorry
it's me adrian osborne oh right
right adrian okay i don't know why it
hasn't come up under your picture but it
hasn't on my screen
but anyway yes
yeah just to uh linda bacon really
um can she just uh has yet uh the date
that they show
on here how long has the this uh
been um
well how long has this been actually
empty and
i'm correcting and assuming that it was
from 2015.
sorry i haven't uh do you know what
you're
what you have in front of you you're
referring to 2015
but i believe
all i want to know is how long has this
building been empty
i think it probably has been empty since
about 2015
16. i think it was empty at the time of
the previous application
i believe and i can't be 100 sure but i
believe
that the the club and the whole
finished or could be 10 years ago but i
think they had caretaker or somebody
living in the building
above on the conservative club part of
it
and i think they were there until
perhaps as you say five or six years ago
i believe it's something like that yeah
and the other question is uh
linda talks about red brick etc but on
the
town council um console t they get asked
for it to be
the brickwork and everything to be
representative of
the old suffolk designs etc which was a
um a white colored brick i believe
i'm not absolutely certain about that
but uh they asked for
at to be be incorporated so
she linda keeps referring it to as red
brick so
um has that not been taken forward
linda the application as it stands it's
still
red brick okay thank you but the
the local colors are a lighter color
aren't they yes the surrounding areas
is is predominantly a galt brick a white
brick
yeah that's right the the town council
did ask for that to be done
well i i think cancer osborne you will
have the opportunity to put that to the
applicant thank you okay
thank you all right um
any other pints of clarification members
yes chair please uh councillor parker
yep thank you check could i just ask
linda to clarify um
which so there is an extent permission
on this site
um i think it was granted in 2017. so
is that still live or has that lapsed is
it about to lapse what's the score there
please
the approval would have lapsed on the
3rd of august
2020 unless they have actually commenced
that development
so without commencement it will have
lapsed
and commencement could be triggered
by demolition work so there's a
possibility that it remains live
but say if it hasn't been commenced in
any way then it has lapsed
thank you kenzler barrett
thank you chair um i don't know if you
can answer this
um uh has has
uh any application been made to have it
listed
it's it's locally listed at the moment
but that's not the same as
uh as as applying for grade one or two
can you help on that or a heritage
officer i'm not aware
perhaps caroline can help carolyn can
you answer that particular question for
us please i
i don't think it has been um i don't
think there is any application to have
it listed
and i'm not sure if that was ever a plan
to do so thank you
okay thank you councillor barrett
any other questions by anybody
i can't see any more hens at the moment
chair
sorry um it's mark russell here
the the permission would have lapsed but
the applicant does have
um dispensation to keep it alive because
of the covid extensions of time which
are brought in this year so
if they perform a paper exercise
involving an environmental statement i
won't go into here they could keep it
alive for a bit longer
all right thank you thank you yes
right there's no uh yet no there's no
other questions
then we're going to move on uh
right public speakers
we don't have a representative from
sudbury town council
or an objector or a supporter
is that still correct
yep i'm taking that as yes so now ask
the agent to speak nick claizeland
you have three minutes in which to
address the committee
are you there
have we lost him rob i'm just checking
check um whilst we're doing that
linda would you mind taking the
presentation off the screen i think
mark's somehow taking control of it as
well
so there's
yeah if you could stop sharing linda
thank you um i'll just check on mr peace
mr peace i'm just here
um yes he was here earlier
can you hear me now we can hear you so
you know rob will you do the timing
thank you
thank you
good morning chairman the members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to address you this morning we had hoped
to be asking you today to make a site
visit to see the condition and character
of these buildings first hand
but understand that you are not in a
position to make such visits at this
time this application follows
significant pre-application engagement
with the council's planning
and heritage officers and also follows a
2015 application for the conversion
and alteration of these buildings to
form five flats
since that application was approved it
has become clear to us that conversion
of the buildings is not viable
and this application instead identifies
a viable way to redevelop these
redundant buildings
we believe it is a well-designed and
cohesive proposal that would regenerate
this
site and provide an enhancement to the
area the town council have agreed with
the principle
of what we are proposing for the site
subject to some minor changes
to the design and materials we've
provided detailed structural information
to justify why this proposal is the only
viable way
in which to regenerate this town centre
site it is recognized that there is a
desire for more of the buildings to be
retained
but we do not believe this is either
practical or based on sound reasoning
in terms of viabilism viability possible
to be frank it is clear that unless the
redevelopment of this site can be made
viable
and practical it simply is not going to
happen it is noted that the government's
recent planning white paper
seeks to provide a quicker process for
renewal areas where regeneration is
necessary
and where it would bring benefits we
consider this is
precisely the case here the design
retains the important
side of the building and the elements of
the new build are of a scale and form
that reflect adjacent development the
materials have been chosen to provide
some interest to the street scene
clearly defining the old and the new the
accommodation provided
is an appropriate mix for the accessible
location
the site is allocated for development in
the local plan
and we believe the proposal meets with
the requirements of policy sd-08
the local plan states that this site can
be redeveloped for housing
so nothing we are proposing is contrary
to what the development plan expects
simply comes down to an assessment
whether the works are sensitive to new
hall
we consider they are and whilst we hear
the views of some of the third parties
they have not been to site and certainly
never entered the buildings their views
must therefore be put into context
little appears to have been made of the
positive aspects of redeveloping this
prominent site on an important free
route in the town
whilst we believe the proposal is in
accordance with the council's policies
we're in the process of seeking further
supporting information to accompany the
application
and are proposing some amendments to the
elevations to enhance the
development further these changes
include suggestions made by the ward
member
councillor jan osborne and the
additional information would include
costings and viability
information that have been requested by
the planet planning officer
as such we would politely request that
this matter is deferred today
to offer the planning officers the
opportunity to take account of the
additional information
and design changes we propose to provide
and then bring this matter
back to you once that information is
available we believe that a deferral of
this item would allow more meaningful
and informed consideration of the pro of
the proposal
in due course thank you
thank you very much for that um i'll
never see if there's any questions for
you i've got one just to start
uh you said that you've submitted new
designs
and that um is that correct no we
haven't actually submitted them yet
but we'd like the opportunity to submit
some design
changes and material changes work with
the um
the planning officer and also together
with submitting a viability statement to
support the application
and would some of these design
improvements
the the colors of the brickwork and
things like that
yes absolutely thank you i'll leave that
for others to
pick up um canceler airs you've got a
question
yes um i'd be interested to know um in
the telegraph yes
it was the um robert generic the housing
secretary suggesting that all new homes
have at least one step free access would
that be considered
sorry one can you repeat that last
sentence one
step free access one step free access
absolutely absolutely yeah yeah that
would be incorporated
thank you uh any any other
questions uh councillor parker
um yeah thank you chair um good morning
nick um
i know your um comments with regards to
the deferral and that will be something
i'm sure that
members will will take into account um
in their debate but um
in the uh in the event that members are
um determined to determine the
application as it were
um could you just tell me about that
design studio is is there a
um is there a use planned for that at
this stage
what and and what would that use be well
we thought it would uh
when we say design studio sort of
gallery art gallery something like that
um there's nobody lined up to take that
at the moment
but it's an opportunity for somebody to
um to move into the building
thank you um could i could i just point
out
to to you um
that the fact that i and perhaps uh
quite a few other members are well aware
of this particular site
um certainly viewed it from the outside
many times
and know it very well um so i'm not sure
whether a site inspection
would have helped but over the years i
have certainly been inside the building
and i know the victoria hall was
certainly
um
in need of uh some urgent um activity
inside
um so i'm not sure whether the request
for the site inspection
was all together necessary but um it is
noted
uh that you did ask for that but you
understand the reasons why
it can't happen at the moment yeah i
fully understand
um the reasons but it was more and more
to view the internals of the building
rather than the externals because i
think we feel it's important for
for everybody involved to to to see the
condition
uh at the internal of the building thank
you right i've got some others now
uh councillor uh busby
thank you just uh a quick thing you've
a lot of three-story houses so i'm not
certain even if you've got a
step free entrance they'll be suitable
for
anybody that needs to access them in
that way
and also there's a lot of four bedrooms
well a lot i mean the majority are four
bedroom houses but there's only a
maximum of two car parking spaces
it looks very tight on car parking
spaces and we know that part of sudbury
there aren't any other air you know
areas that you can really
use so um could there be a consideration
to expand the number of
spaces well the parking um the parking
um
that's been provided um the highways
have no objection with that
they're happy with the numbers provided
um so yeah two spaces per unit is what
would normally be asked for
on a development like this even on
four-bedroom
properties yes
well i think you'll know that two spaces
for a four-bedroom property probably
isn't
enough well that's the county council
highways parking
requirements and i think uh councillor
busby
um they're not far from north street car
park
and uh we we in station road where we
laid a conversion
uh there was no parking provided and
they had to use all the car parks
there which is roy's and weight roads
and what have you um
so there there is other areas where they
could park
but uh i like you like to see park and
on your on their own areas but anyway um
i've still got hands up for suez and and
councillor barrett so i'll go to
councillor barrett
thank you um good morning nick
you um explain the um the process
that you followed uh in prior how you
prioritized
each of the three builds that are all
uh appealing in different ways from a
heritage point of view
um perhaps you could talk us through
that
counselor um perhaps if you asked for
the victoria hall then they
deserve the club and then the new hall
i'm really sorry to interrupt and i
apologize in advance but counselor
hinton has just
shot dropped out of the meeting
thank you yeah so don't answer that
we'll
um wait
members and public we're trying to get
him back
so
uh we continue and i think um in
fairness uh council barry if you'd like
to
uh put your question against mr nick and
we'll take carry on from there this is
still
questions to the agent yeah thank you
it's just
interested to know how you had
prioritized the three individual
elements of the the sort of heritage
um structures um
on the site as they all have different
um
areas of appeal
well we've prioritized the new hall
building at the rear of the site
yeah because obviously that's been um
highlighted as being
uh something of worthy of retention
um obviously the application proposes
demolition of a couple of the bays to
the
uh to the conservative club end of that
building but the approach from melford
road
you would see that building in its
current form um
the the conservative club and the
victoria hall
um if if you had the opportunity of
walking around
internally within the building you would
be able to get to
to consider and and and see
why the buildings are just not worthy of
conversion or
possible of conversion there's been so
much work undertaken within those two
buildings over the years
walls removed partitions knocked down um
floors put in that it's lost
any sort of heritage importance over the
um over the past sort of 10 15 years
really
thank you okay uh now got canceller
airs
sorry i haven't got my hand raised uh
your hand is still raised
uh councillor parker
[Music]
yeah thank you chair um i just want to
strike me down if this question is out
of order chair but
um nick has uh suggested that the
applicant
would favor um deferring this
application now it might be
of course that this committee might be
minded to
determine this application we might be
minded to go against officers
recommendations so
what is the applicant's preference if
that's a valid question um
defer or or press ahead with um with
determination
against officer recommendation if that
was what members were minded to do
well we would prefer to defer so that we
could um
address the additional information that
we've been in discussion with
uh linda bacon uh concerning liability
and and
additional statements and changes to the
materials
and minor design changes thank you
councillor mcconnell uh thank you chair
good morning nick
good morning can i just check with what
you were saying during your presentation
yes did you say that the town can the
town council
actually supported yes town council
sort of agreed in principle what we were
proposing for the site subject
to some minor changes to the design okay
thank you so but they're not here to
support that then are they no today
thank you thank you jeff thank you
there's no other hands up so there's no
more questions
uh to marry your hands still up but
uh all right that's gone there's no
hands up so i'm going to move on
oh jay uh kenzler gold yes sorry
that's funny um just a couple of points
really one is that i know there's only
one
car parking space available for the
design
studio i think in part council of these
questions have received an answer to
that
it's kind of more just just a point that
um a design studio an exhibition place
that people would be expected perhaps to
to come to to see exhibitions um that's
only got one parking space
i just sort of raised that really um and
the other thing is i i don't know
whether this is the point in the
proceedings to to raise this but
do we know what the little community
thinks i mean council mclaren has just
said that
um i'm sorry to interrupt you uh
councillor gold
um at this point as questions to the
applicant
okey-dokey um that question can go to
the officers
uh in debate i will keep that one tucked
under my hat for the approach
if you wanted to rephrase it somehow it
was a question to the applicant you can
do it
oh can i do that how's my mental agility
uh had any support yes indeed so
applicant i wonder i wondering whether
the proposals have had any support
um from the council mclaren says that
the
yeah the town council haven't sent a
representative but um
has there been any support yes there has
um
the general community supportive of the
application
the site is um a bit of an eyesore and
has been for some time now
um and just is desperate need of
redevelopment and regeneration
thank you thank you and in response to
um has there been any um sort of
feasibility as to whether only one
parking space is sufficient
for the design uh and exhibition part of
the new hall
well it would not necessarily be an art
gallery it's only quite a small unit so
it'd be more like an artist
or a you know somebody working from
there at as
out of a studio rather than an
exhibition
uh center because it's a it's quite a
small unit i mean it's in a very
sustainable location
and and as chairman pointed out earlier
on in the
presentation i mean there are public car
parks
uh many of them in and around the town
um
so yeah i mean it's a sustainable
accessible
location um served by railway
and um and bus routes yes
okay thank you thank you thank you chair
right i can see no hands up now
so with that members i intend to move on
so thank you uh mr president and
uh we'll move on to the ward member
penciller jan osborne
[Music]
thank you mr chairman thank you members
the site referred to in this application
has been
standing empty for several years and has
become a real eyesore in sudbury
members there is an opportunity with
this application to at long last
improve the appearance of this site both
for residents and visitors to our town
the application states that the victoria
hall the conservative club
and new hall are on the local list
but apart from the bay windows and the
large cast iron plaque
there is no real significant value
compared to the benefits
of this development would bring to the
town to quote part of the listing
the lower story has become very
cluttered and the soft red brick
generally is in poor condition secondly
it needs a sympathetic new owner
indeed in my view this application is
sympathetic to both the
area and the site i understand that the
applicant is prepared to look at keeping
the base
or a similar replacement on the first
floor
as part of a revised design along with
some other cosmetic changes to the new
build elevations
prior to the application coming to
committee i did request a site visit be
arranged
so that the extent of the damage to the
building can be taken into consideration
this did not take place and i am
concerned that members are being asked
to make a judgment
without seeing the interior of the
building as the exterior does not
portray
how bad the inside is and that the
comments by the heritage
officer are financially unviable for the
applicant
this being the case i would appreciate
the committee giving consideration to
defer in a decision
to enable a site visit by members to be
scheduled possibly by using technology
could i also bring to members attention
the response from sudbury town council
to quote i prove in principle with this
development
town council has felt that the proposed
brickwork that faces directly onto new
street should be sympathetic and in
keeping with the existing street
scene for example white buff brick and
slate tiles
they also felt that the proposed design
of the properties on the existing
conservative club
should resemble the site history unquote
of course i am sympathetic to the views
expressed with reference to the history
of these buildings
but a balance between this and the
benefits of the application
is key to your decision and i am
confident that the members will see that
the balance is on the side of the
benefits
and far outweighs any heritage concerns
if this application is not given
approval there is a risk that the site
will remain in its
current rundown state for many more
years to come
if the application is not deferred i
strongly request that members give this
application
due consideration about the benefits
that will come from this application
rather than trying to protect a building
that is already in a state
of bad disrepair thank you mr chairman
that concludes my report thank you
thank you very much i'll serve as any
questions
to you um counselor gold you've got your
hand up
sorry i just hadn't raised it chair i
saw i just hadn't lowered it
thank you any questions to the ward
member
no thank you then we'll move on
uh right we'll now open up the item for
debate
so it's over to you members uh again i'd
remind you to use the
hands up function but just to kick off
i'll
somebody who's got a hand up i can see
somewhere
that's me chair it's mark russell hello
yes sorry
it's knowing when to sort of speak up in
between the bits of the debate um
i i'm going to ask our heritage officer
just to give a few words about the
um the merits of the buildings just to
explain to members why they're locally
listed and what's important about them
um and i would also at some point like
to remind members of the duties under
the mppf
and the listed buildings act may i do
that now
um well yes
it could come up during the debate um
okay all right
i think that might be better um i'll say
if there's any
uh who who wants to start i'll go to
councillor
ayers uh first and then the hens might
come up after that
cancel ayers um no nothing to say
at the moment but as a town councillor i
totally support
everything that council osborne said
thank you um councillor barrett
uh yes thank you um i was going to
just refer back to that point i was
going to raise earlier um
in the report on page 26
uh there's about the four fifth
paragraph down
it says baber local plan states in
paragraph 7.47
where is that
is that in seven
i don't think it's this document they're
referring to um mark can you help out on
that on page 26
um halfway down the baby local plan i
think it's paragraph in the local plan
i may ask the author if she can respond
sorry perhaps i can help um it is the um
2006 local plan and it's in the
um conservation section so it's 2006.
yes it's the previous local plan not the
core strategy
so it's one of the texts that supports
the conservation policies
right don't even have that
that's a long time ago right um
well before my time so um
also i just wondered if i could ask
linda while you're you're on the
sort of on the line um how are these
buildings on the at risk register
um i don't believe they're on yet risk
register because that would be
for um listed buildings these are
locally listed not statutory listed
right
okay and do you think there is a reason
why they haven't been
an application hasn't been made for them
to be listed
is it because of the poor condition
inside and they already
already sort of
lost a lot of the heritage aspects of
the interiors
um i don't think i could really comment
on why they haven't been
listed because that's dealt with outside
of the council but
maybe carolyn would be able to give you
more insight as to how often they review
buildings for
for listing i think at this point we
will go to carolyn
and asked her to comment on the heritage
side because that's part of your
question yeah hi
yes thank you um in terms of its listing
i think
the changes that have happened
internally likely have something to do
with the fact why it's
it wasn't um considered uh listable
at the time that buildings were being
listed in sudbury
um as well as it might
just not be rare enough
to be nationally protected but
because they still have a um a presence
in the street scene
they have connections to um
so the social life in sudbury and the
community i think that's why they were
put on the
uh on the local list and um
also being in the conservation area they
do contribute to
um the character of the area they use
local materials
and despite the
having been standing empty and the
windows now being boarded up
um they had some very nice
sort of aesthetic details um and it's
in in scale they they fit in into the
character of that area very well
um so i think it's both the ties to the
community
and sort of the local uh local materials
as well as
aesthetic qualities that have
made it on onto the local list thank you
thank you
i've got you lee but uh just following
on from this um
mark did you want to make any comments
on this part of it
i was just going to remind members of
the statutory duties on dmpf from the
list of buildings act at some point
chair um
okay yeah um paragraph 201 201 of the
mppf which is on page 57 um
right towards the end of conservation
section um states
loss of a building or other element and
obviously in this case we're talking
about the loss of a whole building loss
of
one building apart from its front and
then the loss of part of another
building new hall
so the loss of the building or other
element which makes a positive
contribution to the significance of the
conservation area
which these all do they're locally
listed um
should be treated either as substantial
harm which is what it is if you're not
going to building down
um or less than substantial well it's
substantial harm
as appropriate taking into account the
relative significance of the element
affected
and its contribution and significance to
the conservation area
so caroline has just explained how the
buildings contribute to the conservation
area
um their loss they are seen as positive
elements albeit that they are tired in
some places
they are locally listed therefore their
lost would be considered substantial
harm
so we have to really very carefully
weigh up the benefits and dis benefits
well all i was going to say on that
substantial harm or less than
substantial harm
is that your interpretation of that
particular
uh paragraph you've read out or is that
a
fact well it refers to to paragraph 195
um which describes how it would consider
harm and
it left different levels of harm yeah
but so you could have taken
the less than substantial harm but you
feel it is
um substantial harm is that correct
well if you get then go to the first bit
of one nine functions where a proposed
event will lead to substantial harm
or total loss of significance of a
designated heritage asset
uh we should refuse consent um however
obviously these are locally listed so
your grading goes down a bit but you
could qualify it because it's in the
conservation area
as being substantial harm but that that
is open to interpretation
because they're not listed that was the
point i just wanted to be clear on yeah
the other point sorry was paragraph 72
of the um
listed building conservation areas act
so this is our statute duty as as a
planning authority um decision takers
should be mindful of the specific legal
duties of the local planning authority
with respect to special attention which
shall be paid
to the desirability of preserving or
enhancing the character and appearance
of the conservation
area so in other words whatever we
decide today
were we to go for the approval we have
to be happy that what's going
in the place of what we're losing is is
better and that's the second half of the
debate really we're looking at
how good the design might be of the
replacement buildings that was all chair
yeah that's a good point thank you very
much councillor barrett
i'll just come back with a you know
comment that
i think there is substantial harm i
would agree with that
because you're losing it but i think
doing nothing is also
harmful to the these buildings because
not uh you know there'll be no
investment there'll be no
repair upkeep and they will slowly
decline
and become incredibly sad uh and
and as we say they're already in a bit
of an eyesore so
this is a very difficult balance that we
we've got to achieve and
um and i'm trying to trying to um
get get get some um uh
understanding of the real significance
of these buildings i think that's
that's really crucial to this so i'll be
interested to hear what else others say
thank you councillor parker
yeah thank you chair and i i absolutely
concur with everything that um
councillor barrett has said there and um
thank you also to mark for for giving
some explanations so we can get some
context chair is there any chance we
could
share um i think it's slide 13 onwards i
think which are the uh which is the
street scenes
that's correct 13 14 through to 18. yeah
no that's that's what i had are we able
to
put those back on the screen can i ask
the officer to put them up
we'll share the screen and i think you
can still talk over it
yeah excellent yeah um right check so
uh you know so this provides the context
um in in my opinion that uh
when i was reading the report over the
weekend um
you know my initial thoughts as i was
reading through this is going to be
extremely difficult to do anything other
than go with the officer's
recommendation
um because um of the requirements that
we have with regards to the mppf
and and conservation area et cetera et
cetera
um but but this is our alternative
um is if we go with the officer's
recommendation we're stuck with this
um and um i i struggle
to um to to understand
or to be able to justify how uh
retaining this in its current form
um assists and if we can stop on that
slide particularly
um slide 18 if we can just or that one
yeah whichever
um but but yes i struggled to justify
how uh retaining this
for another period of time you know for
a length of time we know
not how long for um enhances this area
at all i mean it's just getting worse
and worse and worse
um and interestingly if we look at this
street
scape here now i know you know the
officers will say well two wrongs don't
make a right
um but there's an awful lot of wrongs
that have occurred here
um over the years um and and
i'm not suggesting for one second that
globe yard which is the modern
uh property shown on the right hand side
there flats i'm not suggesting that that
in any way shape or form is an ugly
building but i'm not sure either that in
in enhanced or preserved the character
um
of
of the area um at the time so
i i'm not i'm not there's there's a
couple of issues here i'm not a fan
of of deferments chair as you know um
but i'm i'm actually thinking that under
the circumstances
uh councillor osborne's um suggestion
and indeed the applicant's suggestion to
defer this
might actually be an opportunity for us
to
just take stock um and and come back and
see what improvements can be made and
whether they can um
you know whether they can satisfy our
offices in
in any way um chair can i leave that
there yeah
i think we would have to also give some
suggestions as to what we
feel they may have to look at or come
back
and discuss with our officers i don't
think we could just defer it
and leave them to talk to officers i
think we've got to give them some ideas
of what we're perhaps
wanting or perhaps what we think might
be an improvement or
we'll just take the br the color of the
bricks for argument um which seems quite
simple and straightforward if we could
have the mooring keeping white ones
uh would they can they would uh we want
that to be considered
very seriously so i think
you could go for the deferment but
you've got to have
some sort of a reason for what you want
the officers
and the agent to concentrate on
but members i think you just need to
bear that all in mind
uh i've got councillor adrian osborne
thank you uh thank you mr chairman um
yes i i concur with the
the comments of uh councillor barrett
and
and that of uh lee parker what i would
like to say is if you put the
um view of the
area you'll notice that there was a a
piece of land
that was part of some gregory's church
which were
like prefab things on there well now
that's now
been done as housing and this um
councillor parker has said the globe
court across the road from it is is
modern as well
i can't see how that impacts on on
getting something done
on on a development which is run down
now for many years
and i think most of the councillors that
are on this committee
have seen over the years areas that have
just
gone on and gone on and nothing has
happened
and we can all we could all list those
those areas
uh and again i'm you know i'm in favor
of of getting something done
to make it look compliant with what
we've got there
but also to make a use of land which is
really required and if if we do
if if members do uh put a proposal
forward to
to go to deferment i would i would very
much like to have
what was suggested by um nick piesland
that
we should be looking at the internal
side of that building
in terms of whether it is done on a
virtual basis
or a um or a if you like an offices
there
well i would like to see i would like to
see the internal
structures of that building and i've no
doubt
that over the years that has
deteriorated
to a point where you've got to do
something about it
and looking and looking at the silk
stuff although
i'm very much involved with uh uh with
with the want of of seeing sudbury
strive on with their silk industry
that has never been used since i've been
in sudbury and
longer than that perhaps you know
yourself mr chairman
as any um manufacturing
positions of silk so again what
you know what are you going to do with
that area with that terrible fencing
it looks it looks atrocious it is an
eyesore
and you know sudbury cannot
in my opinion have many more of these
going on because
you you just it detracts from the whole
position of having
employment and
[Music]
retail actually come into sudbury thank
you
well the decision is within your hands
members so
but i can remember the victoria hall and
i'm going back to
perhaps the year 2000 and just after
where it was flooded on the inside there
was water at the bottom
where the old stage used to be and that
was then
but anyway um i've got two more people
now councillor busby
followed by councilman mclaren
tricky one uh whenever i visit sudbury
it's primarily because of the
the heritage and the interesting
architecture of the
of the buildings if we start
losing these buildings where
individually
they probably don't stack up as being
anything significant
but as a collective then they do give uh
the idea of what the past was like for
sudbury how it grew up
why it was important so i think it's
difficult to start
knocking these things down and losing
them
having said that i've also been in favor
of converting buildings into residential
in town centres for years
because i think that's the future my
concern here
with this particular development is i
guess is on two
fronts one is i think it's probably
over development there's a lot of big
houses in such a small space
and i can understand why they've done it
but
i think slightly
less would give you more
and i think it's it is important if we
can to retain
some of the the detail of those
buildings if they are going to be
knocked down
like the two-tone of the walls you know
the front wall on the back and the side
wall
of the hall we should try and retain
some of this heritage stuff
it is important for sudbury what is
sudbury without
its history if you start just putting
random three-story blocks of houses up
in the middle of the town
then you'll lose it so i'm looking
forward to seeing what the
revised plans will be but my key message
to the developer is
less will deliver more
thank you uh councillor mclaren
thank you chair um i just i used to work
in several years ago so i've got a soft
spot for sudbury
but i am an outsider and at this time
of looking to sudbury to develop its
economic
businesses and we're in a recession
if you visit and pass these buildings
they really are a poor representation
of what is a very active and busy little
town
and i think we should bear that in mind
when we make our decision
thank you thank you
um anybody new wishes to speak
uh no counselor busby hasn't put his
hand down
uh chairman i've got my hand up
kenzler hinton unless the broadband's
playing up and deleting my hand
uh thank you i agree with a lot of what
what's been said by various people but i
think what we've got to consider is that
we shouldn't regard letting a heritage
asset deteriorate as a reason for
knocking it down
um the fact that it's deteriorated is
deplorable
but it doesn't mean to say we should
knock it down i think the design that is
being proposed
for the southern boundary of the site of
the conservative club area
is completely out of context with that
part of sudbury
i admit that just around the corner it's
probably what might be called fast food
city
because every single outlet along there
seems to be a fast food outlet
uh but um there's a certain character to
that part of town that would be
lost completely if
we are going to defer this i think we
are we have got to be
very clear as to why we're deferring it
what i would rather see
is that we go with the officer's
recommendation
and that we give the applicant a clear
steer as to what he needs to resubmit
because let's face it he can resubmit
without a fee
uh having had a refusal and hopefully he
will
then liaise with the various bodies in
sudbury and come up with something that
is more appropriate to that area
because i think the building of four
bedroom houses in the middle of town
like that
is not something that we would require
when we often see
two bedroom homes being proposed in the
middle of the countryside
well what is more logical or illogical
two-bedroom homes in the middle of the
countryside or four-bedroom homes in the
middle of the town
we've got to put what is needed where
it's needed
and not uh just put something in because
it might produce a better return on the
development of the site
thank you any other
comments numbers
counselor barrett yes i think we're
we're moving forward aren't we um
there seems to be a real desire to
retain
the the exterior elements of this and
it's difficult to comment on the
interior so
um but but i i wonder whether there is a
uh that option that the development
could
retain the um the uh
exterior on new street which is the
front of the
grey brick white brick frontage
um if that's not if that's not possible
from a practical point of view can't it
be rebuilt as a
a very very close replica to that
that's after all what's happened in
friar street on the site where the the
fire was in sudbury
and it's incredibly popular people
really have
been very proud of it um it's been very
successful
um and um i i think that is that is an
option for me
um it retains the um the
the the feel of the heritage area the
the conservation area
while at the same time some benefit from
you know the the work behind it that is
modern
modern building methods um so that for
me
would allow this to be more acceptable
if we retained the look of the frontage
on the
new street thank you
uh councillor gold uh yeah um i
i agree with council about and
councillor hinton um
i did take a trip to somebody yesterday
and had a look at the outside of these
buildings
and i do agree they are an eyesore but
i'm not sure
that just because something looks an
eyesore and that it's right to
necessarily demolish it
um and to lose the heritage um
that those buildings have it was
interesting i don't know which slide it
was and i wouldn't be suggesting that we
see the slide again necessarily
but there was one slide that the officer
showed that had got the conservative
building
um she'd superimposed the windows on the
bottom so that we could see what it
used to look like or what it could look
like i think probably what it used to
look like with its windows intact
because any building is going to look
unloved and derelict the minute you put
the boards up
um and i just i i agree with you council
about i just think
um to retain something of the character
i mean the facade is being kept for the
victoria building isn't it the victory
hall um
i'm not a builder i wouldn't be
suggesting that necessarily the facade
was kept but
something of the character of the
conservative club there along that
street
i just feel is important and to demolish
it just because it's an eyesore
and to put up something that is going to
have lost the heritage of those
buildings
that can never be it can never be
returned once something is demolished
from the heritage is gone
that's it isn't it thank you mr chair
thank you thank you councillor osborne
thank you mr chairman um yes i'd just
like to just to
come back uh on melanie barrett's um
position there um if i'm
correct the developer has already stated
that
it is not viable to actually
carry out a restructure of
all of that as it stands they have
already
given um the town council a steer in
terms of that
they would be expecting to retain the
frontage
and always obviously the windows the bay
windows etc in there
and also go with the same type of
brickwork etc
so i'm you know
if it's not going to be viable uh
whatever happens
you are going to have a piece of
so-called listed locally listed um
property that will remain like that
forever
and because no other developer will have
i have the monies in there to do that
i agree with council uh councillor busby
um that perhaps it
it is too much in terms of uh the amount
of flats there
however uh you know they have to
produce that financial uh business plan
for
to to actually get the um
heritage stuff that they've said that
they would uh really
build so i'm sorry but
i i feel you know as a sudbury person
uh for the last 20 odd years that
we are going in a downward spiral and
if we do not get the the stuff back to
to a good position in terms of uh
tourism and in terms of uh people coming
into the town
football etc um john hinton refers to
the
north street as um uh take away city
well
he's quite right there but however that
still impacts on heritage stuff so
like you know i'm i'm a loss to
understand why
we cannot get a a good uh
application in with a developer that is
is proposing uh good changes and keeping
as much of that heritage site as
possible so
i'm i'm sorry i'm i you know it's not
viable it's never going to happen
thank you but thank you for that
um i'm going to ask linda can you tell
us
um because i felt councillor osborne
brought up a good point there
the the facade and the white bricks and
that sort of thing
which he seems to think that the the
applicant has accepted what the town
council has said
do we have any evidence of that um linda
uh in your discussions or are we still
solely just looking at the plans that
are before us
or are there these improvements in the
wings
can you help us yes chair um
we are looking at the plans that are
currently before us however
as of i believe it was monday i did
receive an email
from the um the agent to say that they
would
like opportunity to consider making some
changes and had some suggestions
to how to improve the elevations and
they were also suggesting they could
provide us
with some financial costings which has
so far been
missing from the submission to support
what they
um they propose to do so we we have had
a very recent offer
to provide additional information to us
and hence the request for
deferral right well there's no hands up
um so um i think from the chair i'm
going to
prepare sorry yeah councillor creswell
has got his hand up
i'm terribly sorry i can't see that at
all anyway let me
try and scroll down see whether that
helps
uh well i'm not just believing you
counselor creswell would you like to
comment
you're not hello chair sorry zomb um
what i would say uh reference to
deferment i i sort of agree with janet
um
to beat jan osborne um let's be honest
uh the place has stood up
almost empty for ten years and and i
don't think a few more months it's going
to make a major amount of difference
to get it right rather than to get it
wrong uh
again yes i i've been victoria hall many
a time but
let's be realistic here we've got a
building
and including the conservative club that
hasn't been used for ages and ages
um and i think uh something's got to be
done with the land and
people don't come along with the money
to do the work
needed um and here we have an
opportunity
yes i think the certain things like dave
busby said
maybe too many but at the end of the day
like any developer
they have to make money from a
development let's be realistic
um but i i think if it's not
done it could stand there for another 20
years
before we go back and revisit it so
i do think we have to look at the big
picture
it is an eyesore it stood there for many
many years
um and something obviously needs to be
done with that
piece of land and building thank you
well i totally agree with a lot of your
comments there so
i'm going to make a recommendation from
the chair
that we uh defer this
i'm sorry i put my hand up you don't
mind oh yes i can see your hand i beg
your pardon well
uh cancel a plum
thank you chair um somebody who's been
associated with sudbury
for over 60 years i think they'll have
trump's one or two more
and having driven past this site many
times
i i am somewhat concerned that if we
allow them to knock down any of these
passages then we've lost them and
just as dave buzz we were saying so i
would much rather
hear some suggestions if they got some
um by a referral
then just plowing ahead and saying that
for the sake of
another few months that we can't have
something that's far more acceptable to
us all
thank you right uh well i i'm
going to come in here i can see your
hand mark but i'm i'm
uh i'm thinking that uh deferral seems
to be
um what members are minded to go for uh
so i'm going to propose a
defer deferral that we go back to
the applicant uh with some of the
comments that we've mentioned
find out uh whether there is any merit
in um reducing the numbers or making
them smaller or increasing the park and
or um the color of the brixton design
and the cost of all these so i
i need a secondary i will second that
chair thank you
cancel the plum do you wish to make any
comment not at this stage no
right no mark i'll let you in sorry yes
chair i mean there are two sides to the
debate and obviously we've heard a lot
about the demolition
um i was wondering if linda could just
put the presentation up again so we
could see what's been proposed because
there
were elements of the design that our
heritage officer wasn't happy with
which were um more more need more than
minimal changes for example the bulky
roof
on the right-hand side element that sort
of thing so if you're asking for a
deferral i think we need to be clear
what wants to do afterwards and i would
have to say that the first thing
that we need really is a is a proper
appraisal of the building
and a viability assessment which would
justify
the removal of the buildings if that's
what they're going to go for
if they're not going to knock the
buildings down or going to knock down
less and keep the facades up that does
change the balance
so we need to know what you're asking us
to do
right cancel adrian i was born
yeah thank you thank you mr chairman
yeah um
yeah i'm all for the deferment if it's
going to improve the position of
of getting something done on that site
uh also
i would just like to say that whatever
whatever we do here
for the um not a site visit as such but
the internal structures of that building
should be brought to us so
we can see exactly the extent of the
damage and the
and the problems that have been caused
over the years
and with the same position as yourself
um if we don't and another trevor
creswell in fact
is that if nothing gets done it could be
another 20 years before you
actually going to have anybody with the
finance to to actually be able to do
anything with that site
thank you if we can't get a site
inspection
quite quickly because i don't think this
should go on for too long
can we have photographs taken of the
interior uh
so that they can support the arguments
one way or the other
uh that might be helpful um the
size of the the building or the roof
tiles i think that was an area of
concern wasn't it
um mr russell yeah if
can we have the drawing up i mean it's
the second part of the discussion is the
replacement
do we like the replacement um and there
was the element behind i think it was
the
conservative club part of it where there
was a bulky roof added in wasn't the
linda
which caroline did object to that's
right we can we can point these out
to the applicant and then he can make
comments on them
or um changes as you feel necessary but
i think members we have to be realistic
that there
is a cost to all this and if you want
something done at the end of the day
there may have to be give and take on
both sides
linda
uh cancel the busby while you're waiting
actually uh personally i'm not too
concerned about
retaining the inside i don't know the
inside so i don't know how
important that is it's i think it's the
exterior
to me that's important i think the
victoria hall particularly
we need to keep new hall
has a history a good history that
the fence needs to come down and we need
to make good use of the
the layout of that and i think the
design that they're talking about is
working towards that
um as for the um tory
club well demolishing
i mean it should have been demolished a
hundred years ago
we'll take that pinch of salt council of
busby
right linda are you capable of
coming in see now the um
the elevations in front of you it's the
one at the top on the left hand side is
that's right where your arrow was
so on the left hand side um and
i'd probably ask for carolyn to chip in
as she sees fit but from
my point of view this roof here doesn't
sit
too comfortably because of the um the
little half gables
and hips on the end it's a
it's quite a bit higher the building
behind here
um and the materials we've got red brick
and red tiles um
that's on the uh print street side so
and then turning the corner onto
just to stop you there so that we're
clear the front bit yes i can understand
where
the argument is there but the building
behind in fairness
that is the one in the picture next to
it
the right hand side and they're
basically all the same size
as the new new build or what i've
forgotten what it was called there
so i i think that could be misleading if
we just look at it from that
front view um yes there is some
perspective to take into account here
i certainly think the low part yes that
don't look quite right
but are the slates and tiles and that
all different on those two
see there yes we've got clay plain tiles
here
and the annotations missing but i like
but i believe that slate behind
i believe these pictures yeah
so then turning round the corner onto
new street and the replacement for the
conservative club it's the mix of
materials here as well as some of the
design features because we've got red
brick
and then red cedar cladding that's
horizontally applied
then render then vertical red cedar
cladding
and more red brick and it's a red tile
roof
and then slate so there's
too much of a muddle there a personal
opinion i don't like all that
rendering or um and the cedar cladding
the
typically you'd have black
weatherboarding there's an area of
blackboarding on the
um the former mill next door
and it's some of the the proportions
here um
from my perspective this little um
gablic feature at the top uh together
with
the the height of these because bearing
in mind this was formerly a gap in the
conservation area and is now being
built on by a three-story
dwelling doesn't sit comfortably in that
context but
perhaps carolyn might like to have
further auditions we should never have
allowed the
milhouse one then if we feel like that
but anyway that's the point of view
um yes do you mind if i yes please
celebrate a little bit
the um the mill building is a is a
historic building i believe
so that is that has its place in the in
in the conservation area but
yes like um like linda says there's
putting there's a lot of gaps which
would be filled up by
um by three-story buildings that will
definitely have an impact on the
on on the street view and the variety
of materials and styles together is very
busy
and um contrasts with um
what is a very quite quite simple um
street view that is there right now with
um with the white the white bricks and
as you look down further on to new
street as well there are
smaller cottages with a little bit of
render and a little bit of the
the white brick as well so for it to sit
more
harmoniously and not
contrast as much i would i would
recommend
less less variety in in the elevations
right so just so we can follow this
through
the the roof in um
um there uh is that um
what that's princess street isn't it yes
yes
yeah the roof there uh we'd like them to
re-look at that the uh variety of
materials
on the front which was the old
conservative club which is new street
you'd like them to look at
the variety of the different materials
they're using
too many of them uh possibly the height
of the
um those two buildings there
and see what their views are on that
their fins are picked up at the moment
um members is there anything else dave
busby you've got your hand up
yeah um if you look at the top right
hand
picture of on that slide you've got the
the two
three story buildings i mean firstly
i think it would be better if they a
weren't three story and
b there was only one of them but if
you're going to keep the three story
could you not use one single apex
for your roof which would then mirror
the victoria hall on the left-hand side
good planet would lower the roof height
as well that's another suggestion that
can be put forward
uh obviously the applicants uh listening
in so he can
hear that comment uh any other comments
by members
i can't see any hands
uh yes uh counselor osborne yeah
thank you mr chairman i just um like to
make comment about uh
the the the something that dave busby
mentioned councillor busbees mentioned
and that is that degradation always
works for me inside out so therefore
whatever you're going to whatever bad
bad demolition is required for
inside the building obviously he's going
to go to the outside and
you know you always you always get that
it
goes from inside to out so it's
important that we get a view
of what is inside those buildings thank
you
thank you uh counselor barrett
thank you um
i i i don't for me i don't want to
tinker with
the the modern design because i want
to see the exact same design as
the conservative club is currently um
because
i think it as as we say we
uh we respect it and um want to retain
that
so i my suggestion is that
um that is uh conditional um that
the design is the same well could we
could we not uh suggest that they look
at retaining
some of the features of the uh existing
conservative club in their new build
i think that does open it up that they
could try and put in bay windows and all
the other
things that are there the color bricks
and what have you
yeah that be acceptable to you i
think so i i i i just think it's the the
right scale
the features are nice it's quite fine
actually um
and and and but actually
on a little point um these are two-story
the houses on the opposite side of the
street and further down
uh this street they are all three
stories uh cancel the busby
is quite consistent with the whole
street scene we
are concentrating on looking up the
street but
down that street they're nearly all i
can just see on the corner of that hat
that
that one on the right-hand side they're
all three-story
um because weavers um weaver's cottages
were three stories so they could have
more light allowed into the
the upper floors i i think the point
that cancer was being made about have
them
the one pitch over the two
would be helpful i think so so i think
there's lots of opportunities for the
applicant to look at
and these suggestions that you're
putting forward um
hopefully uh rubble somebody is picking
these up
uh for us uh
yeah this could be because i i
appreciate the
um the sort of collaborative style of um
getting counselors opinions on this but
if we could because it is yours and
counselor plums proposal
could we just clarify the reasons that
we've got specifically so far
um and then go from there because of um
just so that we've
we're picking these up as we go along so
mark i guess that you've
been taking these down as well i've
mentioned some things which i'm not sure
went through to the chair so i just want
to check i mean
the things i mentioned were that we need
um a structural justification and also a
viability statement about why
the demolition is the optimum solution
where there could be a conversion which
obviously we have already given
permission for at some stage
so so that needs to be justified we need
that
and moving forward from that if that's
if that's done fine
and then we look at the design issues
that you've brought up and councillor
barrett has mentioned that the
the facade should be preserved um even
if
the one on the right hand side the
conservative club it has to be rebuilt
she wants it to be like that so that's
that's
the second thing i think has been
requested
uh well my
um point was there was a variety of
materials being used along
there and if that resulted in
uh re rebuilding the front in a similar
form
and that's acceptable then that's fine
that can come back to us
but i think that's all that counselor
barrett has asked them
um it's we want to know their views on
whether they could do that whether they
could make that vibe or whether that
would work from their point of view
from my perspective chair as officers it
is it's feeling a little bit like
not uh it doesn't feel like a committee
resolution it feels like a different
feels like maybe some pre-application
advice we're talking about here or some
other sort of discussion
um whether the things you're asking for
make it a different application
effectively should we come should they
come back with a different application
rather than keep this one running uh
well i i would hope that they'll come
back with a
fresh application uh picking up all the
points that members have
mentioned so so procedures and where
they can
uh um you know take on board some of
those concerns
but my concern was that procedurally are
you asking for this application to stay
open
um or should we look at the refusal so
that the applicant then has 12 months no
i'm not
asking for us to refuse that i don't
think that um
would be the right way to go forward
what we're asking at this point sorry
then that we have to be very clear about
what the um what the
resolution is at this point yeah well
the resolution is to go back and have
discussions with the applicant
uh on a variety of um points which we've
listed uh pointing out that we'd like
the structural
uh survey done um and uh
looking at the roof ruse seeing whether
they can
um do something uh with a rebuild
of the well to as the old conservative
club part uh keep it as near as possible
to what
was there um counselor plum
thank you thank you thank you chair mark
can i just clarify that
if we send it back for deferral yeah and
you start discussions
with the agent um are we in a situation
if
the agent then feels he'd like to submit
a new application what what would this
situation be
because the application has been going
for i think it's 11 months now
the way it works oddly with planning is
if you withdraw a planning application
you have 12 months from the date you
submitted it to get a free go
so they'd only have one month left if
they withdrew so
to be kinder to them counterintuitively
a refusal would be better for them
um better than withdrawing however if
members want to stay with this
application reference and negotiate
within that reference then then we'll
we'll do what you ask
but it may be that we come what comes
back is quite different to what's here
but that that is
that's your prerogative yeah well that's
that's fair enough
some of us don't like what is here and
so something different might be more
acceptable
um counselor i was born
yeah thank you mr chairman i concur with
your your previous uh comments that you
made
uh just just now out but i also would
like to
point out that sudbury town council has
actually
asked for this in this application so
you know why aren't we actually uh
why are we still stating that we've got
all these
changes to do with the uh structural
side of it
when in fact if they've taken on board
what was said by the town council
who actually live with this
every day of the week why why hasn't
that been considered
already and i did pick up from two or
three members
uh during the course of the debate that
there were
benefits that they felt outweighed the
harm
so there there is that that there are
benefits
to that to this whether these are the
right benefits we don't know yet
absolutely right the town council did
speak favorably in the way you suggest
with the
changes but the the heritage specialists
all opposed it so that's yeah there's
the balance well
that's the balance that's different
point of view uh right members i think
we need to
um counselor plum your hand is still up
no sorry i should have taken it down
that's fine uh
right well now have you got these
reasons for us to go for deferment
um so um those mentioned and i don't
know whether there was a
some points were raised but i'm not sure
they went through you to be
anywhere let's find out yeah so there
was a structural survey
yes to the satisfaction of our heritage
officer um the viability uh
well when do you say to the satisfaction
can't they do a survey
and then we can decide whether it's
satisfactory or not
uh well okay it will be done and we'll
look at it
and and if we need some more we'll have
to ask them right i think that's better
yeah
okay um and then
there was the the viability
yes though that we need to be sure of
that
okay and now there are some design
changes which obviously we can't
hold the applicant to it that they may
decide not to they may come back
something different
so we can't design it here no
but the points that were raised were i
think i'm correct in saying
that somebody mentioned keeping the
facade of the conservative club possibly
but i i would presume therefore that's
not possible
then replicating it was the second best
option yeah yeah those those two points
yeah yeah
and and beyond that there are obviously
there are issues of materials and roof
fights etcetera i'm not sure how far we
got with that discussion
well the the roof at the front uh we
didn't like the little bits chopped off
and the other roof i thought councillor
busby came up with a good
uh solution that um you know if one
um pitch was there for the two dwellings
if the two dwellings are kept
uh that would be better so i think that
is something and the variety of
materials
um you know there's too many different
materials going on
okay so we've got hips we've got
materials i didn't catch the point you
made in the middle
about um the the pitch was that the
the pitch of the the two three story
dwellings which have got two pictures
councillor busby suggested we have one
pitch
over the two and that kept in keeping
with the victoria hall pitch
okay question mark right um i think
we're there with that
can i just check with my colleague
robert that we're
this is a good way to do this rob are we
happy that we can do a deferral
with these instructions well uh
thank you uh mr uh russell i forgot your
surname their apologies
um with regards to that yes it's
obviously within the committee's remit
to ask
for um these but there is always an
iodized committee must
bear in mind that they can ask for it
but the applicant may not be
for whatever reason may do it or may not
come back mr russell if that
that's my understanding and obviously
i'm not planning on so that's just my
understanding of it
so whatever comes back before committee
might not have all of the
um requests of what the committee the
only thing i've just added because my
members have i've got on my list as well
members talked about the
um pictures of
um the internals or possibly
um doing that as opposed to a side visit
because if we
as we said about the internal pictures i
didn't know if that you wanted to add
that in as well
well if it's possible we can get
photographs from the inside it will help
i mean it may be it may be something
that may or may not justify
why they want to do a b or c
although the structural surveys is there
then that should be enough one would
hope but
we can certainly get you some football
speak the application photographs for
you as wheelchair for
insight i've got counsellor ayers
yes thank you chair i just maybe could
suggest
that and when the photographs are being
taken either yourself or one of the
sudbury
councillors maybe councillor osborne
could um actually
go in the building as well just a
suggestion
uh i know i think i think the the
photos should either be taken by our
officers or the applicant without
counsellors involvement
okay yeah okay
um right well i think we've got enough
there and yes we are aware that the
applicant need and take any of this on
board but uh
i would just say to him i think he's
heard all the comments he's heard what
counselors have said i think he'd be
very unwise not to take some of them on
board
but anyway that's that remains to be
seen
uh cancel the gold yeah can i just get
clear in my mind
um mr russell please um did you say that
this application has been running for 11
months
and a resubmission could occur within a
12-month period
yeah the applicant's only got a month
to tweak this around oh no no no no
that's sorry i didn't make myself clear
at the moment a decision is made let's
just say we refused it today or approved
it
um well no not approved that's not
logical if we if we refused it um they
would have 12 months
in which to um resubmit
uh free of charge but if they if they
withdrew it
they'd only have 12 months from the date
they first submitted it
which would mean they've only got a
month to get it a free vote you have to
we have to
bear in mind it costs their money to put
an application in costs us money to do
it as well but you know it costs the
applicant money so
we don't want to put unnecessary charges
on them so they're not going to withdraw
it
but were there a decision made they
would have 12 months from that point
to resubmit free of charge that that was
what i thought you said
um and and a comment from you that it
actually might be kind of to the
applicant to refuse this today
so well it doesn't sound like it doesn't
mean you know what i mean
yes i do yeah better than withdrawal
thank you thank you i just wanted that
thank you
we would attempt to get this back as
quickly as
know that's not in possible gift but it
is in the gift of the applicant
i think it might take a little while
given the work required so
i i wouldn't want to increase
expectation of a quick return we'll do
it as quickly as we can but it is
sure we would that's that's the
undertaking
agree with me that if that there was
some discussion between me
as to whether what was being put forward
was such a substantial revision that it
was in effect a
forcing a new application if i mean that
there is
i know the committee's had this issue
before i experienced this issue before
my colleagues
sometimes you you can amend an
application in a fairly minor way
but sometimes the um well you can get to
a point where it's such a radical
revision it's in effect a new
application is really not lawful
to do anything other than go back to
square one or you have the middle
situation that's fairly common where
there are quite significant changes but
where the fairness demands that there's
some further consultation if only with
our heritage colleagues more possibly
with
with the um everyone else who might be
entitled to be consulted
but that'll be something mark and
caroline will have to work out in the
next
um weeks as it were yeah
okay i think we're all clear on that mr
chairman
yes who um it's john henton
and doesn't see when i put my hand up it
doesn't seem to appear anywhere so it's
obviously
no gremlins uh
just a quick one to for mark really
the clock is running on this application
since it was uh
submitted by deferring it is the clock
still running and are we likely to run
into the possibility of an applicant
saying you didn't
decide my application in time and
therefore would it be
safer to refuse and with all these
recommendations for them to come back
um i will ask linda to confirm whether
an extension of time has ever been
agreed on this application
is that the case linda we have
previously agreed an extension of time
so we don't run
that risk of refund but
i'm sure the applicant would consider
extending the time
to allow for these amendments to be
submitted and to bring the application
back in time that's a question we will
put to the applicant
so so briefly uh it won't qualify for a
refund because
an extension time has been agreed at
some point even though it's been going
on for a long time
that's right no reason i've got
counsellor errors followed by councillor
parker
sorry i didn't realize my hand was still
all right councillor parker
well just very quickly char i'm confused
by all of this conversation frankly
because this is exactly what the um
applicant asked for right it is his
presentation so surely he knows what the
ramifications are
absolutely i couldn't agree more with
you right
well i think we've discussed this more
than enough yeah
check with councillor creswell his hand
is up
right sorry i cannot understand why i
can't see his hands
but i can't anywhere uh councillor
creswell
councillor criswell
hello there sorry yeah yeah
i apologize i cannot see your hand for
whatever reason i don't know but anyway
did you want to comment no no no all
right
okay thank you i've still
right i've still got suez hand up if
that disappears
then i'm assuming there is no one else
that wishes to speak
council hinton's sound is still showing
right councillor hinton
obviously some of these hands show on
other screens rather than mine
no he's got it's gone now they're all
right so they're all gone
do people know how to take their hands
down
i'm not going into that one on the top
bar there's a little
yes you you do it right thank you
just before we go to um the next part
could i just confirm with
councillor plum that he agrees with all
of the reasons proposed by yourself
as he is the seconder yes i was coming
to that to ask him whether he was
acceptable what's been
said uh
i'm fine thank you thank you council
so we're all uh satisfied that we know
what we're voting on
so i'll now ask rob to do the roll call
for
um a deferment with the following um
reasons conditions comments and views to
go back to the applicant
without can you just confirm what we're
voting uh
i'll list them again chair um it was for
structural survey
viability assessment retention of or
reconstruction of replication of sorry
the the conservative
club element um new street
and you yeah removal of the hips
um a single pitch roof and changing
materials
yeah yes there's a variety of them yeah
okay
they're all clear rub okay thank you
cheer
so if you could please respond with four
against or
abstain so counselor sue airs
four councilor melanie barrett
four council peter beer
four councillor trevor cresswell
four councillor david busby
mclaren four
council adrian osborne four
custard lee parker four and councillor
stephen plum
thank you chair i make that nine votes
for one vote against and one vote for
abstention
yes thank you mr carmichael i agree with
that thank you thank you very much then
that is carried so that will come back
to us
in due course as soon as possible okay
members
i think we've got to the end of the
meeting
i'd like to thank you all for your
participation this morning
and i'd declare the meeting closed and
we no longer discuss it
you